proclamation calling on the nation to
celebrate the contributions of black
americans honor the legacies and
achievements of generations past reckon
with centuries of injustice and confront
those injustices that still fester today
the president vice president and first
lady second gentlemen cabinet officials
and white house staff will host meetings
and activities this month centered
around the 2022 black history month
theme black health and wellness this
includes a focus on physical wellness
mental health environmental justice
economic growth and spiritual wellness
white house senior staff will also host
important stakeholder discussions on
diversity in media veteran wellness and
increased support for hbcu students last
but certainly not least we will
celebrate and acknowledge the invaluable
role black faith leaders have played in
communities across the nation uh
particularly during the covet 19
pandemic this is of course just a brief
overview stay tuned for more
announcements
zeke with that why don't you kick us off
the president previewed that
announcement last week and then ordered
it today is there something some new
piece of information or intelligence
that he saw in the last few days that
went from the emotional thing to
something that to it to to an actual
deployment
i would not read this as a decision made
based on any events over the last 48
hours or a couple of days
we've been in discussion and under
discussion with our partners and allies
in the region where these troops are
going uh for several weeks now and i
would just outline for you i know some
of you may have watched john kirby's
briefing but just to give some more
specifics uh a thousand service members
from the u.s army's second cavalry
regiment which is based in germany will
reposition to romania in the coming days
secretary austin had discussed this
possibility in this deployment to
romania last week in his conversation
with the romanian defense minister
second we are moving 1700 service
members from fort bragg to poland and
approximately 300 service members from
fort bragg to germany both of these
moves are to supplement existing u.s
force presence in poland and germany
these forces are separate and in
addition to the 8500 personnel in the
united states on heightened alert
position uh posture that we announced
last week but i would also note zeke
just to finish the answer answering your
question that um you know the president
has been clear uh since the beginning of
uh the escalation uh and the in the
building of troops at the border and
been directly clear with president putin
as he was in early december if russia
stays on an escalatory path which they
clearly have we will make force posture
adjustments to deter and defend against
any aggression this is not uh troops
that will go into ukraine they're not
fighting in ukraine uh these this is us
uh this is the united states abiding by
our commitments uh under article five to
support reassure our partners in the
region
what is the the milestone the
president's looking forward to for those
troops to come back home what is the
issue is if russia de-escalates those
traditions we go back to
to their bases is that well i think as
you touched on it's not permanent
they're not intended to be permanent and
again we already had a true presence in
all of these countries where we are
doing an increase in troops
so i can't give you an evaluation
obviously if russia decides to
de-escalate to take the escalatory steps
then certainly that would impact uh what
the forced posture needs are in other
parts of the region senator hawley uh
was at the stadium today saying that the
uh
the president should sort of take nato
membership off the table for ukraine
that wasn't in the u.s to do that do you
think that sort of rhetoric or sort of
you know positioned by a u.s senator
right now it's helpful in this
showdown between the west and russia
well if you are just digesting russian
misinformation and parroting russian
talking points
you are not aligned with
long-standing bipartisan american values
which is to stand up for the sovereignty
of countries like ukraine but others
their right to choose their own
alliances and also to stand against very
clearly the efforts uh or attempts or
potential attempts by any country to
invade and take territory of another
country that applies to senator hawley
but it also applies to
others who may be parroting the talking
points of russian propagandist leaders a
different topic um there's a lot of
reported last couple of days about how
the u.s is setting it on per capita
basis with pure developed countries
the death rate in the united states is
far outpacing what's being seen abroad
largely as a result of the lower
vaccination and boosting rates here as
well some other videos but does the
president feel like he bears
responsibility that you know a year in
office with this new way that the us
wasn't better prepared and that more
people are dying here with a per capita
basis than our
in europe
well the buck always stops with the
president and he would say that uh but i
would also tell you zeke that the steps
that we have taken uh to make progress
to prepare in the united states far
outweigh what almost any other country
in the world has done to date uh that
includes ensuring uh that 87 percent of
the population has had at least one
dosed uh including
continuing to increase the number of
people who are boosted ensuring we are
taking steps to keep our schools open to
make sure uh communities that have
surges have federal resources they need
so of course we are still at war
with a virus that is continuing and and
that is the president's top priority he
has said that before uh but i would also
note all the steps that we have taken to
ensure we are prepared as we have ups
and downs in this uh pandemic
one last one yesterday you mentioned
that it's the policy of the
administration not to no longer comment
on conversations with joe manchin
about it i didn't say joe mentioned i
said
you're often asked me about your mansion
so i think that was the context of the
question which is absolutely fine uh but
it is our policy to not give specifics
or
to to try not to give specifics of
private conversations the president is
having with uh members of the senate
members of congress um there are times i
know yesterday of course we had senator
grassley and senator durbin here and we
did a pool spray of that so you may say
that's contradictory but uh our effort
and our focus is on making progress and
sometimes that means keeping those
conversations private oftentimes
so i'm just sure this is a shift from
where you were a few months ago is that
only because the build that better bill
failed is that is that why this policy
has changed
i think it's a recognition that a lot
more progress can be made when you're
having private discussions
and that the president's focus in terms
of what we're publicly communicating how
he's speaking to the american people
needs to be on what he's doing to make
their lives better not constant updates
on the legislative process
go ahead thank you jen um on the troops
that were deployed today
you've said that they aren't going to be
fighting they'll be there to offer
support can you offer any details about
exactly what they will be doing there
and also about the distribution to these
specific countries why these three
places and and why the 2000 versus 1
000. sure well to be clear they're not
going to ukraine to fight right in a so
i know that's what you were asking but
just for clarity for uh the tr the
transcript purposes um so
this our effort and our uh objective
here has been to ensure we are ready for
every con contingency uh and forced
posture um
increases as part of that preparedness
um it's to reassure our allies uh to
whom as i've said we have a sacred
obligation um this force or these forces
who have gone are trained and equipped
for a variety of missions to deter
aggression and to reassure and defend
our allies in terms of why the specific
numbers i'd really point you to the
department of defense who makes the
recommendations and ultimately uh you
know proposes for the president's
sign-off i would note that a number of
our nato allies have recently announced
troop movements as well uh similar to
what was announced this morning so uh
including the united kingdom france
spain denmark and the netherlands of
their intent to deploy additional forces
to reinforce nato's easter flank eastern
flank as well so this is a reflection of
our uh robust capabilities and our
ability to distribute them across europe
but it's also consistent with a lot of
what a lot of our nato partners are
doing john kirby said that the pentagon
has not ruled out employing additional
troops under what conditions would that
happen
these again are these decisions were
based on
close consultations with our partners in
the region the countries where these
troops have been deployed to of course
and also uh the escalatory actions by
russia but uh you know obviously the
president is meeting with his national
security team on nearly a daily basis
and we'll make evaluations as needed and
then changing topics um senator lupron
has been hospitalized after suffering a
stroke um in addition to offering well
wishes of course some of his democratic
colleagues have said this is a reminder
that in such
a close senate and the unexpected
development could
be a challenge to moving forward
their agenda so has the president spoken
with senator lujan and does he share
similar concerns
not at this point let me just reiterate
i know you referenced them but that we
have all been thinking of senator lujan
and his family i know his team put out
an update on his recovery uh last night
and he's a 49 years old so i would also
note that but i would point you to them
for any specifics on his status of
course we're thinking about him his
family his entire team um at this point
in time
i'm not sure what you were referring to
in terms of uh concerns about for
example senator coons uh brought up
yesterday that you know this could be a
challenge for moving forward
since they
you know that 50 50 split is so critical
so
is that something that the president has
also considered
well life is precious as we know um
you're most familiar with the average
age of senators in the senate um but
that is true on both sides of the aisle
so i would just say uh we spend most of
our time
engaging in good faith uh about uh the
president's agenda uh and not making
those calculations and then just one
more on the supreme court given the
president's commitment to diversify it
will he make similar pledges um should
he have another opportunity to nominate
someone for example there's never been
an asian-american justice or an lgbtq
justice so will he make a similar pledge
well i would say that it about judges or
just in general i i would say that if
you look at the president's record of
judges circuit court judges
lower court judges it speaks for itself
he has had um a enormous number of
justices he judges he has nominated who
are people of color who are women um he
has uh he has nominated and confirmed an
extraordinarily diverse bench of
qualified
individuals to serve on the courts and
that is certainly a priority for him i
don't have any new pledges to announce
for you but i think i would point you to
his record which speaks to his
commitment to ensuring
the court is more diverse uh lower
courts are more diverse
the higher courts are more diverse and
that that is something he certainly can
will continue to look at as a priority
thanks jen go ahead thank you oh sorry
i'll come back to you but
i was just going to ask another
follow-up on the troop movements um is
president concerned that putin might use
them as a pretext to act against ukraine
well i think what's important to be very
clear about here is that there is one
aggressor here that aggressor is russia
they are the ones who have gathered tens
of thousands of troops on the border
they are the ones who are threatening to
invade a sovereign country nato is a
defensive alliance the steps and actions
we are taking are to provide reassurance
and readiness
to our partners in the region if putin
president putin and the russians decide
to do s de-escalate that would be a
welcome step
and follow up on the energy issue qatar
has said it will divert cargos if needed
but needs the u.s to help mediate
changes in supply contracts who is the
u.s talking to about diverting supplies
and are any countries willing to forego
their qatari supplies to help europe i
certainly understand the question i
would just note that we're talking to a
range of countries and suppliers not any
one individual country obviously uh
cutter is a is a large uh supplier of
oil uh in the world uh so that is
certainly a statement of fact but i
don't have any private anything about
our private conversations to read out
from here and just a quick final one
does biden plan to watch the olympics
u.s athletes competing i think it starts
friday yes absolutely we all do i'm not
going to rule out an olympics outfit
here i would encourage all of you to do
the same um yes we are looking forward
to it um and to cheering on our american
athletes who will be competing go ahead
just one more on the troop movements can
you explain a bit more why the president
decided uh to move unilaterally before
nato approved a multilateral deployment
i mean you've talked often in here about
how fiercely united the us is with our
nato allies is there a concern that this
undercuts that sense of unity absolutely
not and this is an important question
because a lot of our nato partners have
done something taken a similar step in
fact five other of our nato allies have
taken steps the united kingdom france
spain denmark and the netherlands have
all said they have the intent to deploy
additional forces to reinforce nato's
eastern flank so these decisions can be
made on a unilateral basis by the united
states or any of our nato partners to
boost up support and obviously the nato
alliance as a whole would decide if
there was going to be a movement of the
nato alliance forces so this is
something that we have always had the
capability to do as in as all these
other countries do as well uh and it's
an option in addition to uh what we've
done to support and plus up our nato
alliance our nato partners our nato
alliance i think it's still not clear
though then why i mean i know we've been
you've been addressing this here but why
now then given that you're saying
there's there's no new evidence that's
come to light necessarily it's not that
you have a sense that putin is going to
invade any more so than you thought a
few days ago that's true but uh and i
just noted that that it wasn't an event
because i think the way zeke asked the
question in the last day or two or over
the weekend or something like that there
this has been under discussion for uh
some time now with our nato partners and
of course within the administration uh
there it is also true uh that um that it
is there's no question that russia and
president putin has continued to take
escalatory not de-escalatory steps so it
is not that it is one moment it is we
are looking at uh
events over the course of time and at
the risk of sounding like a broken
record on the supreme court search uh
has the president made any plans to meet
in person with any of the nominees has
he had any direct conversations with any
of these potential candidates we're just
not going to provide updates from here
on the process certainly meeting with
the nominees will be well obviously with
the nominee but meeting with candidates
will be a part of the process but i
don't expect we'd provide a play-by-play
on that from here
thanks jen two weeks ago at his press
conference the president said quote
we're going to actually increase true
presence in poland and romania if in
fact he moves referring to president
putin he has not moved yet to invade
ukraine as far as we know so can you
explain in the last two weeks why that
calculus has changed for president biden
well i wouldn't say the calculus has
changed as much as we look at a range of
events over the course of time and
there's no question that if you look at
president putin's actions they have been
escalatory not de-escalatory but clearly
he's been this has been a topic of
discussion uh from uh among our national
security team and also between our
national security team and their uh
counterparts for some time now is the
president worried that putin is going to
try to invade a nato ally
the president uh wants to we're
certainly hopeful he would not but the
president wants to uh take steps to
reassure uh our uh our countries in the
region uh that are part of the native
alliance and you know russia as a
country president putin is a is a leader
who has invaded two sovereign countries
uh in the last uh several
several years um you know he's somebody
who's used chemical weapons he's
somebody who's pushed propaganda around
the world uh we're not predicting that
he's made a decision we don't know that
but we're also taking steps to be ready
and to be prepared are removing these
forces that are now being deployed is
that contingent on putin removing his
troops from ukraine's border
removing oh these troops troops in
eastern europe
that the president is sending to nato
allies that he signed off on yesterday
is that contingent on putin
de-escalating not just de-escalating but
actually removing his troops from the eu
if president putin took the escalatory
steps that certainly would impact our
calculus but i don't have anything to
outline from here that's obviously a
decision and recommendations that would
be made by the department of defense one
last question last week i believe in
here you said that you the assessment
still was that a russian invasion is
imminent that's the word that you used
before that other officials have used
and used it last week but yesterday the
ambassador to the united nations linda
thomas greenfield said she would not use
the word imminent she said she does not
think a russian invasion of ukraine is
imminent so i guess we just need some
clarification on where that assessment
stands right now i use that once i think
others have used that once and then we
stopped using it because i think it sent
in a message that we weren't intending
to send which was that we knew that
president putin had made a decision i
would say the vast majority of times
i've talked about it we said he could
invade at any time that's true we still
don't know that he's made a decision
okay so you're not using that word i
think i used it once last week but the
decision now is that you're not
describing it as m a i haven't in over a
week
okay
yeah go ahead jen thanks um
just another question first on uh
president putin and sort of the message
coming from russia um he yesterday
expressed hope for diplomacy and after
um the the us announcement on troops
today the russian uh deputy foreign
minister called the move unjustified and
destructive so how do what is your
response to sort of their rhetoric of
you know calling for diplomacy here
given what their posture is
on the border of ukraine i would say be
very open-eyed about russian propaganda
and what they're putting out there
we know what is happening on the border
everybody can open their eyes and see
they have gathered more than a hundred
thousand troops at the border they have
also built up troops in belarus at
another border
that has not changed we have not seen
de-escalatory actions at the same time
we don't know that president putin has
made a decision to act and that lee
ensures means that we are going to of
course continue to leave the door open
to diplomacy we're going to continue to
discuss and engage
where we can find common ground
with russia with russian leaders that
doesn't mean that we are going to bow um
to what their demands are on issues like
nato and what and the the right of any
sovereign country to be able to choose
which alliances they pursue um we've
been clear on that from the beginning
but um you know diplomacy means you
agree on some things you disagree on
others you try to figure out where
you've common ground and that's the
process that we're still undergoing
um
on another subject um the house is
working through the china bill um right
now
and there were some amendments um that
were released last night
there was an effort by some house
members to attach guardrails to chips
funding which would mean
um they wouldn't be able to get u.s
taxpayer dollars while also investing in
china does the administration have a
view on that
i'm not going to get into any specifics
about the negotiations that are ongoing
um certainly the president is eager to
sign
the competition
bill into law
i would also note that
mr mccarthy made clear he was going to
whip against this bill and let's just
think about um how ludicrous that is um
he is a leader in the republican house
this is a bill that would help address
supply chain issues it would help make
us more competitive with china it would
provide more than 50 billion dollars in
funding to ensure there's chips
manufacturing here in the united states
which would help by the way reduce and
prevent inflation over time in an
industry where one third of inflationary
pressure is coming from which is the car
industry so there are important
discussions happening right now but the
whipping against this legislation
legislation that warranted a great deal
of bipartisan support in the senate is
certainly a question that hopefully
house republicans will have to answer
for and then just another china question
on a little bit of a different subject
which is um the coven tests that are
being sent out by
the federal government
the the chinese company and on health
owns eye health which is one of
providers
they send a 1.3 billion dollar contract
with the pentagon last month
um
for these tests um the administration
concerned about sort of both the the
sort of optics and messaging of sending
something to americans homes it says
says made in china on it at the same
time that you're you know doing this
thing that you consider to be
a positive good for americans um and
just kind of the overall you know
philosophy of giving um federal
contracts to try well well i would say
our objective and continues to be to
increase
u.s manufacturing capacity of tests we
also needed to meet a need that we had
in this country for more tests and a
shortage of tests and the understandable
demand from people across this country
to get tests and make them free and
accessible which required us purchasing
some of those tests
from china in order to meet that demand
but
that doesn't change our commitment to
increasing our us manufacturing to
ensure that we will be able to meet that
demand with products made here in the
united states over the course of time
go ahead thanks jim um yesterday the
national debt uh passed 30 trillion
dollars for the first time
does the administration see that as a
problem or do you share the view of some
economist that doesn't matter
well um the president believes we need
to have a sustainable and responsible
fixed fiscal policy which is why he put
forward ways to pay for his major
proposals he's committed to a
sustainable and responsible policy and
ensuring that our long-term investments
are fully paid for like builds back
better i'd also note that this stands in
significant contrast from the previous
administration and republicans in
congress which passed a 1.5 trillion tax
cut for wealthy taxpayers in 2017 and
didn't pay for it as we look to the debt
which obviously the president wants to
be lower it's important to note that
more than 95 percent of the national
debt was incurred before he took office
the national debt increased by 7.8
trillion during uh former president
trump's presidency which accounts for
about 30 percent of its total so we are
working to address we are working to be
fiscally responsible and that certainly
is a priority to the president okay one
more on afghanistan um
there's a new report up from the u.n
that says that more than 100 former
members of the afghan government and
other afghan allies of the u.s have been
killed since the taliban returned to
power
there are additional reports that um
thousands of afghan allies of the us are
still in afghanistan they're hiding out
they can't get to the u.s because of
issues with a special immigrant visa
does the administration consider it a
priority to get these people out of
afghanistan and if so why are they still
there six months after we withdraw it
we absolutely do and we've we've also
helped thousands of our afghan partners
uh leave afghanistan uh since our full
withdrawal at the end of august as has
been reported there was a delay in or
there was a gap where there were not
flights those have resumed which is a
good sign which will hopefully
enable us to uh continue to get more
people out obviously the president also
met uh with the cuttery leader earlier
this week they have been an important
partner here as we don't have the
diplomatic presence as you well know
that we had prior i would just note that
from the beginning we've been able to
evacuate more than 120 000 people
from afghanistan some american citizens
many of them afghan partners and allies
people who have fought alongside us uh
during the 20-year war um and that is
the largest evacuation since the vietnam
war so i would say we are still
committed to doing this we are not naive
about the challenges nor are we naive
about the conditions on the ground which
is why we are so focused on getting
humanitarian assistance uh to the people
in afghanistan through trusted and
reliable sources but it is a good sign
that the flights are resumed obviously
this was a topic of discussion with the
cuttery's earlier this week as well
thanks jen just on schools new orleans
became the first major district in the
country to have
a vaccine mandate for all students going
to effect yesterday
we know how you guys feel about the need
for getting vaccinated but will the
white house press other districts to
follow in the world steps we will always
uh
we believe that it's up to school
districts to make decisions about uh
what uh steps they put in place and we
would certainly advise all of them to
follow cdc guidance
on the mandate there are a number of
exemptions that parents can apply for
it's pretty easy to get an exemption
does the white house think that sort of
defeats the purpose of the mandate or
is that okay we have exemptions that we
implement in the federal government as
well
uh staying on education yesterday also
uh before the president paused the
student loan debt repayments um i guess
extended the pause in late 2021 it was
supposed to resume yesterday
um
is the department of education
pushing forward any other steps to make
sure that when those payments relaunch
in may
borrowers will be able to make them or
will the president extend that pause
again or is he still considering
executive action to forgive
student loan debt again sure well uh i
would note that no one has been required
to pay a single dime of federal student
loans since the president took office as
you noted he extended
that pause to may to give
breathing room to borrowers who are
still coping with the pandemic
he certainly also supports congress for
providing ten thousand dollars in debt
relief but bill he would be happy to
sign into law i don't have any uh
additional executive orders to predict
at this point in time uh but certainly
uh in may uh if these uh
if this resumes uh the the education
department the education department will
continue working to ensure a smooth
transition to repayment
good thanks jen um last week president
biden and president zielinski discussed
a in the macroeconomic package of
assistance from ukraine um what's the
status of those negotiations
what's the scope and scale of that
package and what's the holdup given that
the economic damage was happening in
real time from the russian threat and
the eu has already announced its own
economic package
uh yes we have been discussing uh with
the ukrainians in economic a package of
economic assistance uh that package and
discussion has been underway
obviously with at the leader level but
also beyond um at this point in time i
think the discussion is with
other counterparts from our government
and theirs about
next steps i mean this was not the first
economic package that we are providing
to the ukrainians we have provided a
significant amount of assistance not
just security assistance but
humanitarian and other economics
assistance
over the course of time so that would
certainly build on that but in terms of
a next step i can check and see if
there's any anything specific to update
you on just to follow up on the troop
levels
why did the president authorize the
deployment specifically to poland and
romania are they considered the most
vulnerable of the eastern flank
countries compared to say hungary or the
baltics and is it because
um
the negotiations with the other
countries haven't worked out or is it
because these are considered the most
vulnerable members
well i think as my colleague um john
kirby conveyed we're also we've left the
door open to additional i have nothing
to predict on that front but uh this was
based on or this announcement and
deployment was based on consultations
and conversations with these countries
where we have sent these troops i don't
have any more details about behind the
scenes conversation to lay out from here
go ahead
thanks jen uh senator graham and
congressman clyburn have been calling
for educational diversity on the court
suggesting the president should uh
choose someone who attended a public
university rather than an ivy league
school for example as the graduate of a
public university me too does the
president who else here is the president
public school
does he have any thoughts on that as a
graduate of the public university will
that factor into his
uh consideration at all sure i certainly
understand the question i've seen their
comments i would say uh the president's
and we we certainly appreciate senator
graham's thoughts and of course those of
mr clyburn uh what the president's
focuses on is choosing from a wealth of
deeply qualified candidates who bring to
bear the strongest records credentials
and abilities that anyone could have for
this role
as you know he has nominated
judges who do not have not gone to ivy
league schools so i think that speaks to
his value for that but in terms of the
credentials i don't have any more
specifics to lay out for you today
related to that though i also just
wanted to ask about
candidates who have already gone through
a judicial confirmation process either
for the district court level or the
appeals court level is that something
the president's going to be taking into
consideration whether they've already
made it through the senate judiciary
committee once before the president's
focus is again uh choosing from a wealth
of uh of highly qualified candidates who
bring to bear strong records credentials
and abilities to serve on the court in a
lifetime appointment uh that is his
focus and also doing that through
consultation with republican and
democratic members of the senate and
experts not on navigating the
legislative process here's one
infrastructure question um the
a number of florida republicans have
complained about the implementation of
the new infrastructure law
uh well certainly governor desantis
senator rubio what are their i haven't
even seen them well i um
among the things they've complained
about is they've suggested this date was
short-changed on bridge funding that it
should have gotten a bigger distribution
they've complained that the everglades
funding that was announced the other
week should have been higher
coming from senators rubio scott and
members of the house delegation voted
against the bill does the white house
have any response to
lawmakers who oppose the bill in the
first place complaining that their share
of the bill
isn't higher it's pretty rich isn't it
i would say first i think the everglades
funding i don't have it in front of me
but i i believe it's in the billions if
i'm correct you may have the exact
number
okay um there is also an enormous i
mentioned this a little bit yesterday
about 90
of the competitive funding that's
available will go to um localities
territories others who can apply for it
and that's why we put out this big book
um just a few days ago so people know
the criteria where they can apply for
that funding um you know i think
mitch lander when he was here quoted i
think a nancy pelosi quote so i'm just
going to quote it you know i don't know
now i can't even remember it but point
is even if you vote against it you still
want the money we've seen that over the
course of time
that speaks to how political a lot of
these votes were given this is uh this
is funding that will help rebuild a lot
of these communities um and the
president will certainly be making clear
um who was with them and who wasn't with
them
go ahead
last week the vice president's appealed
to governors to help with the defense of
voting rights um
does the administration feel that uh the
effort for national voting rights
legislation is is dead and if so is it
now going to focus its efforts at state
level
we have to do both um so federal
legislation is important for a number of
reasons including that it creates a
baseline of requirements
requirements standards and states so
people can know who are fearful about
how they can vote when they can vote if
you're a mom of three kids you should
have a lot of options for dropping off
your ballot or going to vote early um
and ensuring those requirements are
standard across states it also ensures
that for states that have histories of
voter suppression
that they would have to seek approval
from the department of justice to make
changes that's a good thing uh so we're
gonna have we're still fighting for
those the president has said he will
fight for those until his last breath at
the same time what i think the vice
president was talking about and she will
be
playing a vital role in is working with
states and localities on how we can
fight against oppressive voter
suppression voter laws that are popping
up in states how we can empower and
engage populations to ensure they know
what their rights are um so we're we're
going to do both and it's important to
do both and now mitch mcconnell said
today given current coded facts and
science it is time for the state of
emergency to wind down but does the
president agree with that and is that
still possible when there's that
hardcore of anti-vaccination people
well i didn't see the full context of mr
mcconnell's comments i will say that the
president's view is that um we're not
going to live like this forever we don't
want to live like this forever and uh
our objective and our goal is um is on
ending this uh pandemic as we know it
today so we don't have it uh it is so
it's not something that's disrupting our
daily lives um we do more we'll do more
and more to protect people and
accelerate the path out of this pandemic
there is a lot of progress that's been
made 210 million people are fully
vaccinated that's nearly 75 percent of
adults we had less than one percent
vaccinated when the president took
office about 98 of schools are open uh
and we understand the sentiment that i
think he's expressing even if i haven't
seen the full context we're of course
looking at uh when the time comes what
it will mean to end the pandemic as we
know it today uh but right now uh what
our focus is on is ensuring uh we're
implementing the tools that we know that
work as we're still continuing to fight
the virus
thank you jim uh
the pentagon says that poland and
romania requested u.s troops u.s
deployment
have you received similar requests from
other eastern flank countries baltic
states and what will trigger
additional troops deployment to the day
standpoint and i'm gonna have one more
sure um so i'm i'm just not gonna detail
those private diplomatic conversations
um i've pointed to the pentagon if they
want to share any more detail i'd be
surprised if they did uh but certainly
we
those conversations are continuing um
they're not done um and i think my
colleague john kirby made that clear
during his briefing today and one more
has president biden consulted this
decision with
the leaders of the republican party and
how does does he feel about their
support because there were some voices
on the american right
questioning president biden's
policy towards
russia ukraine crisis
well i would say that we have had an
enormous amount of um
we've done an enormous amount of
briefing and engagement uh with
democratic and republican leaders uh
about the decision-making and how we're
approaching uh the escalatory nature of
russia's behavior on the border um
leader mcconnell or senator mcconnell
made some comments uh in that regard
last week and this is an issue in our
view that should not be partisan what
we're doing here is we're standing up
for what have long been bipartisan
american values which is standing up for
the sovereignty of a country ensuring
that they have the right and the ability
to choose their own alliances supporting
them with a range of economic
humanitarian and security assistance and
doing that in a way that's coordinated
with our partners and allies uh there
are some uh from the republican party
who have uh not uh not voiced support
for that um and again as i said a little
bit earlier in the briefing if you're
echoing you're in if you are digesting
russian misinformation and parroting
russian propaganda you may be on the
wrong side of this issue go ahead
hi
um two questions yeah the first um does
the president know who leonard peltier
is
sure he does but i have not discussed it
with him just call me let me know
he knows um
is he aware of the push by democratic
senators and members of congress and
native state legislators and even pope
francis at one point to
to send peltier home from prison
i have not discussed this with him
specifically i'm happy to see if there's
any more follow-up my second question is
about um the supreme court um some
republican senators like ted cruz are
criticizing biden for saying he'll pick
a black woman for the supreme court he
said it's quote unquote offensive
because somehow the black woman he
chooses wouldn't be the most qualified
for the job but republicans like cruz
also celebrated when trump picked amy
tony barrett
for the supreme court with cruz telling
barrett during her confirmation hearing
quote your children have been
wonderfully well behaved i think you're
an amazing role model for little girls
what advice would you give little girls
so my question for you is why do you
think
republicans like ted cruz are acting so
angry about biden picking a black woman
for the supreme court when they were
very happy when trump picked amy barrett
for the court i read that exact quote
yesterday i'm glad glad lots of people
are following it um
you know i i think that's really a
question for senator cruz uh but it is
important to note as you just did in
your question that uh there has never
there was never an objection by senator
cruz uh to donald trump promising he'd
nominate a woman uh in 2020. you noted
what he said to the woman he nominated
in the hearing and how he applauded her
in the hearing um the notion of the
president's view is the notion that
there has not been a black woman ever on
the supreme court in 230 years is a
problem with the process not a lack of
qualified uh credentialed people to
consider and nominate uh and uh you know
that's his view but i i think that's a
question best for senator cruz
what's the difference between trump
picking amy fenny barrett and and saying
he'd pick a woman in advance and and
fighting picking a black woman that's
exactly why i called out this issue
yesterday but i am blissfully not a
spokesperson for senator cruz so he can
best answer that question
all right thanks emily
yes
uh senator schumer is currently coming
here today to meet with the president
about the supreme court pick and process
can you confirm that do you have any
other information on what their
conversation i believe it was under
discussion to figure out how they could
connect whether it was on the phone or
in person um let me see if i can get
more details on it but it's part of the
consultation process that you've seen
take place over the past couple of days
thank you everyone
[Music]
intermediate please get into our palm
room doors
you